was sie hier sieht ist das great barrier
reef in australien es ist die heimat von
mehr als 1400 korallenarten neben nemo
und story ist das riff aber auch die
heimat eines eher unüblichen rohstoffes
nämlich bakterien
denn vielleicht werden uns korallenriffe
wie dieses hier in zukunft helfen häuser
zu bauen
tatsächlich eignen sich nämlich die
natürlichen bakterien der hilfe um
zement herzustellen so eine
bakterienkultur wird mit einem aggregat
gemischt und in einer wässrigen lösung
wächst so wirklich zement kaum zu
glauben aber backsteine aus diesem
zement sollen genauso hart und
wetterbeständig sein wie herkömmliche
steine und das beste daran ist so wäre
die produktion von zement nachhaltig und
komplett co2 neutral
aktuell stellt die produktion von
backsteinen nämlich ein echtes problem
für die umwelt dar
jedes jahr werden 1,2 milliarden
backsteine hergestellt und dabei ganze
800 millionen tonnen co2 ausgestoßen
einerseits ist die produktion solcher
materialien durch bakterien super
spannend andererseits ist sie ein gutes
beispiel für ein revolutionäres konzept
das die welt für immer verändern könnte
was das mit einem t shirt aus kaffeesatz
zu tun hat und warum klopapier
vielleicht bald eure abwasserrohre
reinigt dazu heute mehr bei doktor
watson
[Musik]
die produktion von bausteinen aus
bakterien nutzt nachhaltige und
erneuerbare ressourcen um eine
umweltschädliche produktion zu ersetzen
würde unsere gesamte wirtschaft in diese
richtung umdenken dann nennt man das
bioökonomie bioökonomie
das ist ökonomie also wirtschaft gepaart
mit nachhaltigen umweltfreundlichen
ressourcen und produktionsweisen also
zum beispiel kleidung aus recycelten
pet-flaschen oder wiederverwendbare
kaffeebecher bioökonomie begrenzt sich
aber nicht nur oft wieder verwendbare
oder recycelte produkte sondern
erstreckt sich über alle sektoren hinaus
kraftstoffe aus biomasse lebensmittel
verpackt mit nachhaltigen rohstoffen
oder sogar kleidung aus kaffeesatz für
eine komplette bioökonomie müssen
industrien umdenken in der
landwirtschaft der chemieindustrie oder
auch in der autoindustrie alles von der
produktion über die verpackung bis hin
zum ende des lebenszyklus von produkten
würde nachhaltig sein
dabei soll bioökonomie kein neuer
wirtschaftszweig sein sondern vielmehr
ein umdenkprozess für die wirtschaft
sprich nachhaltige innovation und
rohstoffe besonders wichtig ist dass
wenn es um recycling geht denn aktuell
haben wir viele produkte die wir einfach
wegschmeißen
entweder weil sie nicht repariert werden
können oder weil sie vom hersteller
nicht mehr unterstützt werden
eine nachhaltige bioökonomie dagegen
wäre kreislauf orientiert das heißt im
besten fall verlässt kein teil der
produktion irgendwann den kreislauf ein
südafrikanisches unternehmen nimmt zum
beispiel alte autoreifen um damit neue
straßen zu bauen das gleiche macht ein
australisches unternehmen mithalten
druckerpatronen dieser asphalt hält
sogar länger als herkömmlicher
straßenbelag diese projekte gibt es
heute schon hier ist natürlich nicht die
komplette produktionskette nachhaltig
vielmehr werden hier umweltschädliche
produkte weiter verwendet anstatt sie
wegzuwerfen
trotzdem zeigen solche initiativen die
richtung an in die es gehen sollte in
einer idealen bioökonomie werden ohnehin
schon wie ökonomisch hergestellte
produkte weiter verwendet theoretisch
würde man also in zukunft nachhaltig
produzierte druckerpatronen oder
autoreifen weiter verwenden um straßen
zu bauen und idealerweise würde man dann
auch noch diesem straßenbelag nach der
abnutzung weiterverwenden
so will man langfristig große
industrielle mülldeponien vermeiden also
den kreis schließen
hierfür braucht es innovation und neue
technologien denn biologisches wissen
und fortschrittliche technologien sind
pfeiler eines zukunftsfähigen
nachhaltigen und klimaneutralen
wirtschaftssystems die aktuelle
wirtschaft setzt zu großen teilen auch
verfahren die auf fossile brennstoffe
angewiesen sind
das wissen wir eigentlich alle aber auch
dein smartphone ist ein gutes beispiel
denn es benötigt wertvolle rohstoffe für
die anreicherung von gold werden zum
beispiel manchmal urwälder gefällt dann
wird ein smartphone auch noch mit
plastik verpackt um mit flugzeugen über
die ganze welt verschickt um in all
diesen sektoren umzudenken braucht es
neue ideen und verfahren
ein japanischer hersteller hat jetzt
schon den ersten bio touchscreen
vorgestellt
dieser wird mit einem nachhaltigen
plastik hergestellt welches komplett aus
zucker besteht ob der screen dann auch
lecker schmeckt viele hersteller
ansätzen auch zunehmend auf alternativen
zur plastikverpackungen wie zum beispiel
recyceltes papier und für lieferungen
und logistik arbeiten namhafte
hersteller zunehmend an elektro batterie
lkw oder sogar an co2 neutralen
wasserstoff flugzeugen
in zukunft wird es besonders spannend
sein zu sehen welche innovationen auf
uns warten
aber auch jetzt schon gibt es sehr
innovative neue produkte zum beispiel
hat ein italienischer hersteller einen
toilettenpapier entwickelt das mit
bakterien angereichert ist
keine sorge die bakterien setzen sich
erst frei wenn das papier sich im wasser
auf weicht dann aber können sie fette
und organischen abfall auflösen
so werden beim abspülen tatsächlich die
rohre gereinigt eine funktionierende
bioökonomie scheint also die lösung
für sämtliche umweltprobleme der zukunft
zu sein oder mit einer nachhaltigen
kreislaufwirtschaft würden wir praktisch
kein co2 mehr produzieren und somit den
treibhauseffekt komplett stoppen
na ja das ist natürlich noch sehr
utopisch denn auf kurze und auf lange
sicht würde so ein umdenken immense
anforderungen an firmen und produktionen
stellen aber das erwartet auch niemand
dass wir uns von heute auf morgen in
eine komplette bioökonomie verwandeln
schritt für schritt orientieren sich
erste firmen in eine bio ökonomische
richtung einerseits bestimmt aus
überzeugung aber auch weil es sich
mittlerweile ganz oft lohnt auf
nachhaltigkeit zu setzen
wirklich rein vom geld her schon jetzt
könnt ihr wenn ihr eine bioökonomie
unterstützen wollt bewusst die jedoch
davon
die ökonomischen produkten oder services
werden in vielen deutschen großstädten
gibt es zum beispiel bereits verpackungs
drei supermärkte und die supermärkte
sparen geld weil sie kein geld für
verpacken und ausgeben müssen
auch viele hygieneprodukte haben
inzwischen nachhaltige alternativen zum
beispiel eine zahnbürste aus bambus
anstelle von plastik zahnpasta tabletten
ohne verpackung oder auch wieder
verwendbare wattestäbchen
das sind alles mega interessante
entwicklungen und wenn euch all diese
unternehmen und deren ansätze
interessiert haben dann habe ich jetzt
gute nachrichten für euch denn je mit
staaten wie auch doktor watson so etwas
wie eine kleine serie
das hier ist die erste folge für das
wissenschaftsjahr 2020 bioökonomie und
im laufe dieses kommenden jahres werden
wir verschiedene teile der bioökonomie
genauer unter die lupe nehmen
zum beispiel werden wir uns nachhaltige
kleidung oder auch interessante bio
ökonomisch unternehmen und vieles mehr
genauer anschauen um keine folge davon
zu verpassen vergesst nicht den kanal
hier zu abonnieren
vielen dank an die gemeinnützige
organisation wissenschaft im dialog und
an das bundesministerium für bildung und
forschung für die unterstützung bei
diesem video wie immer vielleicht fürs
zuschauen und bis zum nächsten mal
bleibt neugierig neuester trick